لدينا هذا الفيديو
الذي يُظهر تدمير
ناقلات جند مدرعة روسية من قبل
القوات الأوكرانية ، والآن
يقول مسؤول دفاعي أمريكي كبير إن الروس يواجهون بعض
التحديات اللوجيستية التي أوضحت
أن البعض منهم تعرف نقص
الوقود لبعض التحديات الأخرى
كن على ما
يرام ، فإن التحديات الأخرى هي عندما
تتحدث عن استخدام صواريخ مضادة للدبابات
أه كلها مثبتة على الأرض ، فأنت
في منطقة تختلف عن الصحراء
التي تعلم أن الولايات المتحدة
تقاتل فيها في أفغانستان والعراق
حيث لا يوجد  الكثير من الأشجار ليس
الكثير من المباني في هذا النوع من الأماكن ،
ولكن عندما يكون لديك قوات مدرعة متحركة
تنزل في الشوارع حيث توجد
مبانٍ وأشجار ، يمكنك إخفاء هؤلاء
المشاة بالأسلحة المضادة للدبابات
داخل تلك المواقع وما يحدث
هو متى وأغلبها
لقد تعرضت هذه المركبات التي تراها للهجوم من
الخلف بصدق وسأعترف بذلك
لأن الناقلات في بعض الأحيان لا تنظر
خلفها ، لذلك عندما  يتسلل المشاة
خلفهم حاملين أسلحة مضادة للدبابات
أه يلتقطون الدبابات
وناقلات الأفراد ، كما
يطلق عليهم
في شوارع المدينة ، من السهل
نسبيًا القيام بذلك ، وأعتقد أن القوات الأوكرانية
تقوم بعمل جيد للغاية
لمحاربة  المدن الآن
ستشير إلى شيء سيء ما
سيحدث بعد ذلك ، أعتقد لسوء الحظ
أننا سنشهد جرائم حرب إضافية
ارتكبتها قوات السيد بوتين الكثير من
المدفعية ربما تقدمًا جويًا لكن
القوات الأوكرانية قامت أيضًا بعمل
جيد جدًا في جوها  الدفاع ، لذا مرة أخرى
يعود الأمر إلى النقطة التي مفادها أن السيد بوتين لم
يكن يعرف ما الذي كان سيواجهه مع
هذا وكان جنرالاته من وجهة نظري
غير أكفاء من حيث الطريقة التي
خططوا بها لهذه العملية